- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La première va être posée
par monsieur Loïc Kervran
pour le groupe Horizons.
- Loïc Kervran: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
de l'Education nationale.
J'y associe mon collègue
Lucas Miro.
Dans le Cher, mais aussi
dans de nombreux autres
territoires ruraux,
les directeurs académiques
s'apprêtent à fermer
des classes rurales
par dizaines,
dans des proportions inédites.
Nous regrettons
que trop souvent,
en lieu et place
de la concertation nécessaire
sur l'avenir de nos écoles
en ruralité,
il n'y ait que le déploiement
d'un processus
de déconcentration
des moyens
dans les plus grandes communes.
Cette concentration
sans concertation
se fait au détriment
de la cohérence
des politiques
publiques en faveur
de la ruralité.
Dans le Cher, l'inspection
académique veut fermer là
où les élus ont investi
dans la rénovation
de leurs écoles,
là où on ouvre
des gendarmeries,
là où on crée
des accueils périscolaires.
Comment croire
que c'est en fermant
des classes que l'on combattra
la perte démographique
de beaucoup
de nos communes rurales?
Il est urgent
de changer la logique.
Où est l'égalité
quand le même chiffre
de 15 élèves reste
l'objectif à atteindre
dans les écoles
de banlieue est l'arrêt
de mort de nos classes
en ruralité?
Ca fait des années
que nous demandons
à revoir la carte
d'éducation prioritaire
pour qu'elle puisse
prendre enfin
en compte la ruralité
et ses spécificités.
Il nous faut
faire une pause
dans le vaste
transfert de moyens
de nos campagnes
vers les villes
et se donner la possibilité
de réfléchir sereinement
au futur de nos écoles
en ruralité.
Pour moi, qui suis un enfant
de la campagne,
un élu de la ruralité,
qui a mes enfants
dans l'école publique
de mon village,
cs classes
ne sont pas des lignes
dans un tableur Excel.
C'est une question
d'aménagement
du territoire.
C'est la vie de nos enfants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Amélie Oudéa-Castéra.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le député,
votre question
est cruciale, car elle aborde
le double sujet
de l'égalité
des chances et d'équité
entre les territoires.
L'école rurale
se caractérise
par une bonne
performance scolaire
des élèves,
mais leur ambition scolaire
et d'orientation peuvent
permettre parfois
que ce soit moins soutenu
qu'en milieu urbain.
On a accéléré dans le cadre
du plan France Ruralités
avec trois décisions fortes.
La première, donner
une meilleure visibilité
sur trois ans aux évolutions
de la carte scolaire
en prenant bien en compte tous
les secteurs ruraux
avec le bon niveau
de maillage
et de lecture.
Deuxièmement,
installer
dans tous les départements
une instance
de dialogue
et de concertation,
qui est coprésidée
par le préfet,
et qui réunit
des représentants
des associations
et des maires ruraux.
Cela sert à partager
les informations
et à conduire
des analyses collégiales.
Troisième décision,
soutenir les territoires éducatifs
ruraux qui permettent
de renforcer
la prise en charge
pédagogique et éducative
de nos enfants.
Concernant les décisions
qui doivent
être prises
dans les prochains jours
au sujet de la carte
scolaire,
si dans certains départements,
des concertations complémentaires
s'avèrent nécessaires,
je m'y engage,
elles seront menées
sous l'autorité
des préfets.
Notre école doit
être la même pour tous.
Elle a évidemment un avenir
tout particulier
dans nos ruralités.
Elle a une place
essentielle à y jouer.
Je ferai de la place
de l'école
dans nos ruralités l'une
de mes priorités
au sein de ce ministère.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
madame la ministre.
La parole est à madame
Laurence Robert-Dehault
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Laurence Robert-Dehault: Merci.
Madame la ministre,
en février 2023,
le gouvernement
utilise un énième 49.3
pour faire passer
l'impopulaire réforme
des retraites.
Ce rabotage
sur les droits sociaux
se justifie
par une promesse:
remettre les comptes
sociaux à l'équilibre.
Le gouvernement souhaite
encore réaliser
des économies sur le dos
des Français, aujourd'hui.
Le reste à charge
médicale va doubler.
Les Français devront
payer 1 euro
par boîte
de médicaments,
2 euros pour les consultations
des médecins, 4 euros
pour les transports sanitaires.
Le ministre de l'Economie
nous explique
que ces montants
n'avaient pas été augmentés
depuis leur création.
Ce gouvernement sera
donc le premier
à le faire.
Le gouvernement poursuit
dans sa politique
de paupérisation des Français,
qui souffrent déjà
des déserts médicaux,
entre autres.
Nous faisons face
à une pénurie de médicaments.
Les signalements
de rupture de stock
sont en hausse
de 128% par rapport
à 2021.
Nous vous alertons
depuis des années.
Depuis 2022, les prélèvements
obligatoires n'ont jamais été
aussi élevés.
Pourtant,
les Français
ont de moins en moins de droits.
La solidarité nationale
doit s'exercer
pour nos classes
moyennes,
selon le Premier ministre.
Après sept ans
de gouvernance macroniste,
il est temps
de s'en rendre compte.
Notre Sécurité
sociale ne protège
plus nos compatriotes.
Notre modèle
de solidarité nationale
ne profite plus aux Français.
Selon l'INSEE,
la différence du poids
des aides sociales
dans le revenu
des familles mérite
l'application
le plus rapidement
possible du principe
de priorité nationale.
A quelques mois
des élections européennes,
le Premier ministre
a multiplié
les appels du pied
envers les classes moyennes.
Ce sont elles qui vont subir
cette hausse
de plein fouet.
Madame la ministre,
le gouvernement va-t-il cesser
ses mensonges
et assumer clairement
qu'il continuera
de ponctionner
les Français des classes moyennes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Catherine Vautrin.
- Catherine Vautrin:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée,
je crois
qu'il est important
qu'on se dise
les choses tout à fait clairement.
Le modèle social français
est un modèle unique.
Il est tellement unique qu'il n'a
été copié nulle part ailleurs
dans le monde.
Sa spécificité,
c'est qu'il fait peser
son poids sur nos concitoyens
qui travaillent.
C'est clairement un sujet.
Le Premier ministre
l'a rappelé hier.
Ce poids du modèle social
a des conséquences
très concrètes sur la vie
de nos concitoyens.
La santé
est dans notre pays l'une
des meilleures du monde.
Je crois que c'est le moment
de redire
tout l'engagement
des professionnels
de santé dans notre pays.
Nous sommes excellents
en matière curative.
Nous le sommes moins en matière
préventive.
Cela m'amène
à vous dire un mot
sur la responsabilité
qui est celle
de chacune et chacun d'entre nous.
Non, la santé n'est pas gratuite.
La gratuité, ça n'existe pas.
Il y a toujours
quelqu'un qui paye.
Aujourd'hui,
quand on a des besoins
de santé, qu'on ait
un premier objectif
qui est la prévention
pour garder
son capital,
c'est la première chose
que chacun d'entre
nous doit faire.
Ca ne coûte rien.
Comment pouvons-nous
participer à l'effort?
Et l'effort
à un moment où les uns
et les autres ont des choix,
mettre 1 euro
sur sa boîte de médicaments,
c'est prendre conscience
de la valeur de ce médicament.
Il faut avoir le courage
de le dire
à nos concitoyens.
Ce n'est pas
de la démagogie,
c'est la réalité
de la responsabilité.
C'est le sens du message
que nous devons partager
avec les Français.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la députée?
- Laurence Robert-Dehault:
Madame
la ministre, l'AME est gratuite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole pour le groupe
Gauche Démocrate
et Républicaine est à monsieur
Jean-Marc Tellier.
- Jean-Marc Tellier:
Madame la présidente,
madame la ministre
de l'Education nationale,
chers collègues,
depuis des mois,
l'Education nationale
vit à travers
une avalanche de déclarations
et d'annonces ministérielles.
Nous assistons à un choc
des paroles qui,
malgré leur fracas
médiatique,
sont surtout déconnectées
des véritables enjeux
de notre école publique.
Dans ce contexte
de communication superficielle,
aucune proposition
ne vient répondre
aux attentes
et aux besoins des élèves
et des enseignants.
Sous le couvert
du renforcement,
c'est surtout un retour
en arrière
où l'Etat
n'assure pas à chaque élève
la possibilité
d'avoir le même bagage
à la fin de sa scolarité.
Ces annonces, dépourvues
de toute promesse
de moyens supplémentaires,
vont creuser davantage
les inégalités sociales.
Il est temps de parler clairement.
Les enseignants qui manifesteront
demain attendent
des réponses.
Ni la généralisation
des uniformes
à l'école ni la mise
en place de classes
de niveaux ne gommeront
les inégalités sociales.
L'inclusion ne doit pas rester
un simple slogan.
La carte scolaire
doit être réformée
pour garantir
une égalité d'accès
à l'éducation dans nos villes,
nos quartiers
et nos campagnes.
Partout en France,
la dégradation
de notre école continue.
Dans mon département,
le Pas-de-Calais,
force est de constater
que la future carte scolaire
prévoit la suppression
de 89 postes.
Pourtant, chaque jour,
c'est 96 classes
qui se retrouvent
sans professeur,
faute de remplacement.
Rien que sur ma commune,
cinq postes seront supprimés
pour 19 enfants en moins.
Je sais
que les remplacements
sont un sujet
qui vous préoccupent,
alors quand deviendront-ils
une priorité absolue?
Madame la ministre,
quand le gouvernement va-t-il
renouer avec l'école
de sa République,
avec l'école de l'égalité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Amélie Oudéa-Castéra.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra:
Monsieur
le député, l'égalité des chances,
l'attractivité
du métier d'enseignant
et plus largement,
comme l'a montré
le Premier ministre,
la focalisation
sur l'ensemble des métiers
du service public
d'enseignement
sont absolument au coeur
de notre politique éducative,
au coeur de notre ambition
pour l'école.
Toutes les écoles
de la République.
Je voudrais souligner
que la carte scolaire
est le résultat
d'un travail continu
entre des services
académiques départementaux
en lien étroit
avec les collectivités locales,
et les ajustements
de cette carte scolaire,
qui sont parfois
exigés par l'impact
des politiques publiques
ou l'évolution
de la démographie,
doivent se faire
en concertation
avec les élus,
et j'y veille personnellement.
Sur le sujet
des remplacements,
qui est une problématique
décisive,
nous avons décidé de la traiter
prioritairement.
De premières mesures
ont été impulsées
par Gabriel Attal
pour nous permettre d'améliorer
notre organisation,
de faire aussi recours
aux heures supplémentaires,
et de créer
de nouvelles
incitations
pour que les enseignants puissent
davantage remplacer
leurs collègues
dans le cadre du pacte
que nous évaluerons.
Sur tous ces sujets,
vous connaissez
notre engagement,
notre envie de faire réussir
tous les élèves,
de faire réussir
toutes les écoles pour remettre
en marche l'ascenseur scolaire.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole est à madame
Cécile Untermaier
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Cécile Untermaier:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Economie.
L'indice de perception
de la corruption publié hier
par Transparancy
International
n'est pas bon.
Il situe notre pays
à la 25e place,
très loin derrière le Danemark,
la Finlande, l'Allemagne.
Selon cet indice,
nous payons le manque
d'exemplarité
du pouvoir exécutif,
un système
judiciaire fragile
et le manque
de moyens consacrés
à la délinquance
économique et financière.
Sur le premier point,
les derniers signaux envoyés
sont mauvais et aggravés
par la nomination
de ministres
qui n'emportent pas
tous la confiance
et le silence
sur la proposition réitérée
de l'observatoire
de l'éthique publique
de nommer un déontologue
au gouvernement.
Sur le dernier point,
c'est le développement massif
du narcotrafic
dans l'économie
qui nous préoccupe,
un développement
qui trouve son terreau
dans une corruption
sans limite.
Hier, lors de la déclaration
de politique générale,
le Premier
ministre a rappelé
que la France
n'était pas n'importe
quel pays, qu'elle dispose
d'un héritage morale remarquable,
et a affirmé
devoir identifier
tous les ressorts
sur lesquels on peut agir.
Gouverner n'est pas facile,
mais l'engagement
dans une politique
publique de lutte
contre la corruption
doit être totale.
Elle doit nous rassembler
et être débattue ici,
en séance publique.
Alors, monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie,
sur quels ressorts
le gouvernement entend-il agir
pour combattre
cette corruption
qui mine la démocratie
et ruine la confiance
des Français?
Etes-vous partant
pour engager collectivement
ce combat et en débattre ici,
en séance publique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la députée,
nous sommes évidemment ouverts
à avoir un débat sur ce sujet.
Je partage
votre préoccupation
et notre ambition
avec le Premier ministre,
l'ensemble de la majorité,
est de lutter
contre la corruption.
Le classement
que vous mentionnez
nous fait gagner une place.
Ce n'est pas beaucoup,
mais au moins,
ça va dans la bonne direction.
Si nous voulons
continuer à progresser,
et je partage
votre ambition,
le pays des Droits
de l'homme,
de la République,
doit être exemplaire
en matière de lutte
contre la corruption,
du trafic d'influence,
des conflits d'intérêts
dans le secteur
public comme privé.
Nous avons des instruments
efficaces.
Pour le public,
la Haute Autorité
pour la transparence
de la vie publique.
Nous avons l'agence
de lutte anticorruption
qui a été créée
il y a quelques années,
qui est extrêmement
efficace
et qui fait un bon travail.
Nous voulons,
avec le garde des Sceaux,
aller plus loin
dans les mois qui viennent.
Nous leur avons demandé
de travailler
à un nouveau plan
contre la corruption
sur lequel nous sommes prêts
à travailler
avec l'ensemble
des parlementaires
qui sont présents.
Le ministre
de la Justice le sait,
nous avons augmenté
de 60% les moyens
de la justice depuis 2017.
Nous avons fait
le maximum
pour nous donner
les moyens de lutter
contre la corruption
et pour être exemplaires
dans ce domaine.
Enfin, un dernier mot
dans la référence
que vous faites
à ce rapport, je rappelle
un point important:
la lutte
contre la corruption
ne doit pas
se faire au détriment
de la présomption d'innocence,
qui est un principe
cardinal
de notre justice
et de notre droit.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la députée?
- Cécile Untermaier:
J'entends vos propos rassurants,
et je vous remercie,
mais je pense
que la bonne direction
serait de poser
le débat de la Cour
de justice
de la République.
Il serait aussi
de poser le débat
sur le renouvellement
de Anticor,
qui est un outil
utile à la justice
et contre la corruption.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Laurence Heydel Grillere.
- Laurence Heydel Grillere:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, il doit
y avoir une exception
agricole française.
Il faut mettre
l'agriculture au-dessus
de tout.
Ces mots
que vous avez prononcés,
les agriculteurs les attendaient.
Investie
depuis plus de 30 ans
sur les questions
agricoles,
sur la qualité
de l'eau et des sols,
j'ai accompagné
nos agriculteurs face
aux impasses techniques
et sanitaires, face
à la prédation,
la guerre des prix,
la paperasserie,
toujours à la recherche
de solutions.
Contrairement
à ceux qui veulent interdire
ou détruire
les réserves d'eau,
ceux qui remettent
en cause l'élevage,
ceux qui veulent interdire
des molécules autorisés partout
dans le monde,
ceux qui prétendent
que l'on peut faire
sans l'Europe
et qui vont à la rencontre
des agriculteurs
pour la première
fois, contrairement
à ces opportunistes,
la majorité
a fait le choix d'accompagner
nos agriculteurs.
En réponse
à leur demande,
vous avez pris
une décision ferme
sur le GNR.
100 inspecteurs
ont commencé leur contrôle
dans le cadre d'Egalim.
250 millions d'euros
ont été débloqués
pour trouver des alternatives
aux pesticides.
Un fonds d'urgence
est déployé
pour nos vignerons.
Un grand nombre
de mesures qui répondront
au moins pour partie
à la crise agricole.
L'agriculture est multiple.
Loin des grandes
terres cultivées
ou des grandes terres
d'élevage, l'Ardèche,
mon département,
se caractérise
par la diversité
de ses productions
avec des cerises,
des châtaignes,
des plantes aromatiques,
de la volaille,
des élevages, des exploitations
de petite taille
très diversifiées
avec des productions,
des difficultés techniques,
des impasses, voire
des importations à bas coût.
Ma question
est la suivante:
face à la diversité
de notre agriculture,
comment comptez-vous
agir pour permettre
à chacun de nos agriculteurs
de vivre
de son métier
tout en retrouvant
notre souveraineté
alimentaire
et en accélérant
notre transition écologique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée,
merci
pour cette question
qui me permet,
en mon nom, mais surtout au nom
du Premier ministre,
de saluer
votre travail
en tant que députée,
mais aussi à l'ensemble
de vos collègues.
Vous n'avez pas attendu
que les caméras viennent
sur les points
de blocage pour aller
à la rencontre
des agriculteurs,
des viticulteurs.
Je pourrais citer beaucoup
d'autres députés.
Vous avez toujours
été au contact,
et grâce à ce contact,
grâce à ces échanges,
vous avez pu faire avancer
un certain nombre
de lois qui étaient attendues
de longue date.
La loi Egalim 1,
Egalim 2, Egalim 3,
mais également
l'assurance aux récoltes.
Si certains se lamentent
sur les aléas climatiques,
vous avez fait face
pour faire voter
la réforme de l'assurance récolte.
Nous allons continuer
sur la base
du travail entamé par le Premier
ministre lui-même
dès la semaine dernière.
Dés annonces ont été faites.
Des mesures très rapides
sur les normes,
entre autres.
Nous continuerons
également à Bruxelles.
Le président
de la République sera
à la manoeuvre demain
pour continuer
à défendre
cette exception agricole
dont nous sommes fiers.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Aurélie Trouvé.
- Aurélie Trouvé:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le ministre
de l'Economie,
depuis une semaine,
c'est le festival
des promesses creuses
pour répondre
à la colère des agriculteurs.
Ils vous demandent
de les protéger
des importations
à prix cassés,
mais depuis 25 ans,
l'Europe et la France multiplient
les accords
de libre-échange
avec un but:
gagner des marchés
pour les grands
groupes de l'industrie
et des services en décimant
l'agriculture française.
Depuis sept ans,
le président Macron finit
de sacrifier les agriculteurs.
Il a ratifié
un accord
avec le Japon,
Singapour, le Viêtnam,
le Chili,
la Nouvelle-Zélande,
et il soutient les accords
avec le Mercosur,
l'Australie, l'Inde,
l'Indonésie,
la Thaïlande.
Vous nous dites:
"Pas d'inquiétude,
j'engage un bras de fer
avec Bruxelles",
en endormant
les éleveurs français
avec des clauses miroirs.
Ca ne vous dérange pas
d'avoir des dizaines
de milliers de tonnes de produits
importés d'Australie
ou du Brésil.
Le coût du foncier
y est presque nul.
Les abattoirs géants
dans lesquels
le SMIC n'existe pas!
C'est une concurrence
insoutenable
pour les éleveurs.
C'est vrai aussi
pour la pêche,
les fruits, les légumes.
Comment faire croire
que vous protégez l'exception
agricole française?
Ca fait des semaines
que le président Macron
nous répète
que la France a mis fin
aux négociations avec le Mercosur.
C'est faux.
Le vice-président
de la Commission européenne
a rappelé hier
que les négociations
se poursuivaient, comme prévu.
Monsieur le ministre, stop.
Notre agriculture
se meurt
de votre folie dérégulatrice.
Une autre agriculture
est possible
à condition de la protéger
des multinationales
et de la concurrence
internationale.
Vous devez convoquer
un Conseil européen.
Vous devez retirer la France
des négociations
de tous les accords
de libre-échange
en cours.
Le ferez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire:
Madame la députée,
tout d'un coup,
La France Insoumise découvre
qu'il y a des paysans en France.
Après avoir proposé
des augmentations
de taxes,
des augmentations d'impôts,
des durcissements
de règles et de normes,
vous venez au soutien des paysans.
Il n'est jamais
trop tard
pour bien faire.
S'agissant du Mercosur,
je vous rappelle
qu'il n'y a qu'un
seul Etat en Europe,
par la voix du président
de la République,
qui s'oppose
à la signature en état
et de l'accord Mercosur,
c'est la France
et le président de la République.
Nous avons réussi à bloquer
ces négociations,
parce que nous estimons
que cet accord
est injuste et qu'il mettrait
nos éleveurs dans des difficultés
insoutenables.
Il n'est pas question
de laisser entrer
sur le sol européen
des dizaines
de milliers
de tonnes de bétail
qui ne respectent pas nos mêmes
règles
que pour nos producteurs.
Je vous rappelle
que c'est grâce
au président
de la République
et à la négociation
avec le gouvernement chinois
que nous pouvons
exporter des porcs
de Bretagne
et que leur prix a augmenté
parce que nous pouvons
les exporter
vers la Chine.
La balance commerciale
avec la viticulture augmente
car nous pouvons
exporter du vin
vers le Japon.
Nos producteurs de lait
sont bien contents
de pouvoir exporter
50% de fromage
de plus vers le Canada.
Ne tuez pas l'agriculture
française
avec vos mauvaises
idées, madame
la députée.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à présent
pour le groupe écologiste,
madame Sabrina Sebaihi.
- Sabrina Sebaihi:
Madame la ministre
des Sports, un enfant
sur sept est victime
de violences dans le sport.
Un bénévole sur deux ne fait
l'objet d'aucun contrôle
sur ses antécédents judiciaires.
La plate-forme de signalement
des violences sexistes
et sexuelles reste méconnue.
Vous avez reconnu
ces dysfonctionnements.
Pourtant, votre priorité
depuis 10 jours
a été d'attaquer
le travail du Parlement
et de notre commission,
et cela au mépris total
de la séparation des pouvoirs.
Ce rapport a pourtant
été largement salué
par les victimes
pour lesquelles
vous n'avez eu aucun mot.
Ce rapport vous dérange
car il vient bousculer
votre caste de privilégiés.
Il démontre que la France
n'a pas totalement tourné
le dos à une logique
aristocratique d'accaparement
du pouvoir, digne
des descriptions
de Balzac, qui écrivait
sur le faubourg Saint-Germain.
Ce système vous permet
de maintenir
quelques familles au pouvoir.
Nous sommes passés
d'une société privée
à une grande
fédération sportive
avec à la clé
un salaire jugé anormal
par l'inspection
générale placée
sous votre autorité.
Dire aujourd'hui
que l'on perd de l'argent
en étant ministre,
que 500.000 euros
de salaire en étant
dirigeante est mérité,
cela doit ulcérer
nos agricultures
qui bloquent les routes
en ce moment
pour toucher
ne serait-ce qu'un SMIC.
Dans votre monde,
les grandes familles
se croisent et s'associent.
Tout cela incarne bien
la transformation
du président
de la République
entre sa première
élection et la fin
de ce second sacre.
Il nous avait promis
le nouveau monde,
il va nous léguer l'ancien régime.
Puisque dans votre monde,
il est normal
de toucher 500.000 euros
pour les heures
de travail "enfournées",
quelles considérations méritent
les agriculteurs,
les professeurs
et les bénévoles sur le terrain?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Amélie Oudéa-Castéra.
- Amélie Oudéa-Castéra: Bon...
Madame la députée, donc,
vous recommencez
à m'attaquer personnellement.
Je vais d'abord
vous remercier
pour votre question,
qui est l'occasion
pour moi de saluer à la fois
la présidente Bellamy
pour son effort constant
d'objectivation
des travaux
de la commission d'enquête,
et de remercier chacun
des parlementaires
qui y ont contribué
et qui ont contribué
à la bonne marche
de ses travaux
avec un objectif:
faire progresser
le sport.
C'est le mien aussi.
Je vous en remercie.
Simplement, ce travail
parlementaire
de qualité,
vous l'avez dévoyé
dans votre rapport,
dans l'atterrissage,
puisque vous vous
en êtes servi
pour stigmatiser
sur les plateaux télé,
dans les réseaux
sociaux
ou par des formules
à l'emporte-pièce.
Vous l'avez fait
par opportunisme
pour surfer
sur la vague médiatique
des crises
des fédérations
que nous avons gérées,
que nous avons solutionnées.
Arrêtez de donner des leçons.
Où étiez-vous,
depuis 2020,
quand le gouvernement
a pris à bras-le-corps
comme aucun avant
lui le sujet
de la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles
et sexistes dans le sport?
Où étiez-vous en novembre
dernier lorsqu'on
a discuté les crédits
pour le sport
pour 2024
avec des moyens inédits
que nous avons réussi
à décrocher
pour la lutte
contre les violences?
Vous étiez absente.
Vous étiez absente de ces débats.
Moi, j'ai poussé
pour les signalements,
la progression du contrôle
d'honorabilité!
J'ai été aux côtés
des victimes
et je continuerai à l'être.
Madame la députée,
je suis fière
du travail
que nous avons entrepris
et lucide sur ce qui reste
à accomplir
pour améliorer
notre modèle sportif.
Ce combat pour l'éthique
mérite mieux
que de vaines attaques
politiciennes.
Ce combat pour le sport,
nous devons
le mener et le mener
tous ensemble.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Louise Morel
pour le groupe démocrate.
- Louise Morel: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre
de la Transition écologique
et de la Cohésion des territoires.
J'associe à cette question
monsieur Laurent Croizier,
député du Doubs.
Ma question concerne
MaPrimeRénov'.
L'agence nationale
de l'habitat a annoncé
qu'elle prévoit
une baisse de 30%
des forfaits MaPrimeRénov'
pour l'installation d'équipements
de chauffage fonctionnant au bois.
La réduction
sera effective
dans quelques semaines à peine.
L'annonce est brutale.
Elle est sans
concertation
avec une filière qui,
pourtant, se structure
depuis des années
pour accompagner
la transition énergétique
de nos bâtiments.
Cette décision marquera
un coup d'arrêt
pour les chaudières
au fioul
par des chaudières biomasse
plus performantes.
Cela va à l'encontre des objectifs
environnementaux
et de réindustrialisation
de notre pays.
Je dois préciser
que l'inquiétude
est vive pour la pérennité
des 450.000 emplois directs
et indirects
de cette filière,
qui je le rappelle,
a été mise à rude épreuve l'an
dernier lors de la crise
des granulés
de bois.
Les prix ont bondi
de manière exponentielle.
Le volume des ventes
a diminué de 72%
en un an.
A l'heure où nous devons
être vigilants
sur notre consommation
d'énergie,
ces annonces semblent en décalage.
Elles inquiètent
nos concitoyens,
en particulier
ceux qui vivent
dans les régions
les plus froides
de notre pays.
Pouvez-vous nous faire
part de l'intention
du gouvernement à l'égard
de cette filière
qui participe à renforcer
l'indépendance énergétique
de la France?
Et plus globalement,
dans les discussions
à venir sur l'énergie,
quelles actions entendez-vous
prendre sur la place
des granulés
de bois dans notre mix
énergétique afin
de se prémunir face
à une nouvelle crise?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu:
Madame la présidente,
madame la députée,
MaPrimeRénov' a été
une multiplication
par 10 du nombre
de rénovations
depuis 2017, par rapport
au quinquennat précédent.
Une partie de ceux qui,
hier, sont montés
à cette tribune
pour donner des leçons,
pour expliquer
que sur le plan écologique,
nous n'avions
rien fait, je dis
que les 70.000
rénovations par an
ont été multipliées par 10.
La marge de progression,
c'est le nombre
de rénovations
performantes
et le fait
d'être certains
que nous aidons
les Français à faire
les bons choix
avec une priorité:
sortir du fossile.
Autour des questions
sur le bois,
il y a des débats.
Certains considèrent
que si on pousse
trop une filière
de chauffage au bois,
ça pourrait
desservir
ce que nous avons à faire
au titre
de la biomasse.
On a augmenté les moyens.
+1,6 milliard
pour l'année en cours.
On a amélioré les règles
avec un pilier performance
et un pilier efficacité.
Ce dispositif
n'échappe pas à une partie
des critiques posées
par le Premier ministre
sur la nécessité
de débureaucratiser.
Le 15 février
prochain,
dans quelques jours,
je réunirai
les artisans pour regarder
dans le détail
ce que sont ces irritants
qui sont extrêmement légitimes,
parfois.
On a des biais de calcul
sur les petites surfaces
de DPE.
On doit faire attention
à ne pas aller
trop loin en laissant
une forme de neutralité
à l'échelle de l'Etat
et en mesurant qu'avoir
une vision unique
partout en France
du type de vecteur
à utiliser
ne correspond pas aux réalités
du territoire.
On doit être capables
de regarder
cette question
de production d'énergie
de manière transversale.
Je le fais avec joie
avec Bruno Le Maire,
qui est en charge
de la production d'énergie.
Nous allons faire en sorte
d'avancer ensemble
pour planifier
la transition écologique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Paul Molac.
- Paul Molac: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Agriculture.
Je me suis rendu lundi
sur plusieurs barrages
à la rencontre
des agriculteurs du Morbihan.
Si les annonces
concernant la suppression
de la taxe du gazole
non routier,
pour laquelle
je vous avais interrogé
en novembre dernier,
ont été bien accueillies,
elles ont été jugées
insuffisantes.
Je me fais ici le relais
de leurs revendications.
Deux points essentiels:
la surréglementation
et les négociations du Mercosur.
Le choix de sanctuariser
les prairies
avec impossibilité
de les retourner
après cinq ans d'existence
pose problème,
ainsi que la nouvelle
norme européenne.
On ne nous ferra pas croire
qu'un poulailler
de 1500 mètres carrés
est une usine.
Ce n'est pas possible.
Que nous disent les agriculteurs?
Ils nous disent:
"Vous nous demandez
de mettre en place
de nouvelles normes,
on peut
le comprendre,
mais ne nous mettez pas
en concurrence
avec des produits
qui ne sont pas faits
avec les mêmes normes sociales
et environnementales."
Ma question est simple.
Aurez-vous
une majorité demain
pour que le Mercosur
soit remis en cause
au moins sur les accords
agricoles?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Monsieur
le député, merci
pour votre question.
En l'absence du ministre
de l'Agriculture,
je réponds.
Nous sommes à cheval
sur des sujets
sur lesquels,
au nom de l'écologie,
on finit par susciter parfois
une forme d'énervement
ou d'excitation.
Il faut le dire,
elles sont parfois légitimes.
Elles le sont pour deux raisons.
D'abord, si on a des règles
qui s'appuient
sur une exigence écologique,
comment expliquer
que ceux qui se prétendent
pour la planète nécessitent
des règles
en France
qui ne s'appliquent pas
dans d'autres endroits
du monde?
Derrière Mercosur,
c'est la question
du carbone.
On ne peut pas
à la fois regretter
la déforestation et de l'autre
accentuer cette déforestation
en laissant entrer
des produits qui,
avec un dumping social
et environnemental,
aggrave le problème
du défi écologique.
Vous évoquez
une directive compliquée.
Elle est compliquée
pour tout l'ouest
de la France.
Elle aboutirait
à ce que l'on classe
comme ICPE une partie
de ceux qui travaillent
sur la viande blanche.
Il y a deux problématiques.
D'abord, comprendre
la nécessité
des règles et des contrôles,
mais s'étonner
qu'on puisse avoir des normes
qui n'ont rien
à voir, avec des fermes-usines
qui comptent 10
ou 100 fois
le nombre de truies
ou le nombre de poulets
qui seraient autorisés
sur notre territoire.
L'hypocrisie
ne peut pas servir de base
à une écologie punitive.
Si nous avons des règles
qui sont bonnes
pour la planète,
il faut les appliquer partout.
Si en prenant
des décisions en France,
on met sous cloche
une partie
de notre activité
et on augmente
les importations,
ce ne sera bon
ni pour l'écologie
ni pour la planète.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
- Paul Molac: Oui,
je vous rejoins.
Nous n'avons pas à exporter
nos gaz
à effet de serre
ou nos produits phytosanitaires
dans d'autres pays.
Nous devons
produire
chez nous ce
dont nous avons besoin
pour nous nourrir.
J'attire
votre attention
sur le fait
que les agriculteurs
sur les barrages attendent
des réponses précises,
et il ne va pas falloir
tarder
à les leur donner.
Sinon, nous allons aboutir
à une désespérance.
Nous avons besoin
de choses concrètes.
Le discours du Premier
ministre hier
n'a pas suffi à calmer la colère.
J'en appelle
à votre bon sens
et à des annonces
rapides pour calmer
la désespérance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Francis Dubois.
- Francis Dubois:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le Premier
ministre,
notre ferme France brûle
et vous regardez ailleurs.
Votre gouvernement,
avec l'aide de l'Europe,
prépare le plus gros plan
social jamais vu,
un plan social
imperceptible et sournois
pour les agriculteurs
où ils disparaissent
un à un.
Ce ne sont pas les annonces
faites vendredi
avec une botte
de paille en guise
de pupitre
ou les cinq petites minutes
d'hier dans votre discours
qui suffiront
à calmer la colère
des agriculteurs.
Ces mises
en scène
ne sont pas à la hauteur
des attentes
de nos paysans.
Ils attendent des mesures
conjoncturelles,
immédiates,
structurelles et fortes
pour permettre
à notre agriculture
de rester
championne du monde
grâce à son excellence
et à sa durabilité.
Face à un marché
international dérégulé,
à un pacte vert
européen étouffant,
une économie nationale
suradministrée,
il est primordial
de faire
de notre agriculture
une priorité
de la nation,
de la souveraineté alimentaire
une cause nationale.
Nous avons présenté
ce matin,
avec mes collègues
du groupe LR,
un livre blanc contenant
des mesures simples
et de bon sens.
Il faut que vous preniez
en compte
ces propositions.
Il ne faut pas mettre
sous le tapis
tout cela.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre,
je vous exhorte
à passer des paroles
à l'action.
Prenez des mesures immédiates.
Sanctionnez
ceux qui ne respectent
pas les lois Egalim.
Il faut lancer un moratoire,
le temps d'évaluer l'utilité
de toutes les normes.
Stoppez
toutes négociations
sur les traités
de libre-échange
tant que vous n'avez pas réussi
à imposer
les clauses miroirs.
Sauvez notre agriculture,
notre souveraineté alimentaire.
Il y a urgence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Prisca Thevenot.
- Prisca Thevenot: Merci.
Merci, madame la présidente.
Je pense
qu'il y a deux démarches
et deux attitudes, ici.
La première
consiste à chercher
des coupables
en permanence, une autre
à trouver des solutions.
Nous devons
nous attacher à trouver
des solutions.
Non, ce n'est pas la faute
de l'Europe.
de ce gouvernement,
ni même des anciens
gouvernements
qui avaient jadis
voté la loi LME,
qui donnait
les grands pouvoirs
à la grande distribution.
Les lois Egalim
sont venues réparer cela.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui,
sur les différents sujets
que vous avez énoncés,
que ce
soit les clauses miroirs,
les négociations commerciales,
oui, nous sommes à la manoeuvre.
Le Premier ministre a fait
un certain nombre d'annonces
vendredi dernier.
Il était encore hier
soir et ce matin
avec les représentants syndicaux.
Nous continuerons à travailler.
Sur cela, oui,
je vous demande
de nous rejoindre
dans ce travail,
dans cette volonté
d'avancer
pour ces femmes,
pour ces hommes
qui travaillent au quotidien,
pour prendre soin
de leurs bêtes
et de leur territoire.
La porte est ouverte.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La séance des questions
au gouvernement
est terminée.
La séance est suspendue.